okay so it's about 6 30
a.m at the time of this recording um
obviously just heart-wrenching waking up
to the the manchester
terrorist bombing and and now
i don't know exactly what's happening in
the in the philippines it's it's just
unfolding
um just a pit in my stomach
and you know i know that outrage is easy
and you see it a lot on both sides but
particularly on the right with just the
finger wagging
and sort of false patriotism in um we're
still going to write comedy tonight
we're still going to do what we can to
try and create a show but but
i i think that whether it's journalism
or outrage
or even comedy
uh
it serves no purpose if there isn't some
kind of a seeking
for truth and i don't mean
your truth i don't mean
uh finding a truth i mean the truth
there's no living your truth there's the
truth
um
let's get let's get down to some some
concrete a lot of other people are are
are trying to avoid talking specifics
let's talk some specifics right now i
just read the daily beast they arrested
the man in association right now a
suspect with a manchester terrorist
attack
and they said you know we need to uh
fight
the route i think the influence of these
violence it's difficult to fight the the
values the influence the influences of
the violence something along those lines
but refuse to say islamic terrorism
we don't know that yet
necessarily we do know that apparently
in in the philippines it is islamic
terrorism um listen if you want to
practice islam in in sort of the the
inconsequential guy in the sky
semi-secular sense uh fine
but i think it's time to acknowledge
that
political islam as prescribed by
muhammad the political practice of islam
is completely inconsequential with the
west
what do i mean by that well okay let's
nail down some some some concrete values
let's exclude terrorism for a second uh
do you believe in any sharia courts
whatsoever in western culture
you're not welcome
here do you believe that it's okay if
you marry a six-year-old
you're not welcome do you believe that
it's okay to beat your wife for any
reason at all
you're not welcome do you believe in any
kind of punishment not only death any
kind of a punishment for apostasy or
people leaving the faith of islam you're
not welcome do you believe in any kind
of punishment for blasphemy as you see
with with zuckerberg and facebook saying
they're going to crack down on
anti-islamic blasphemous posts do you
believe in any kind of punishment for
blasphemy
you're not welcome
these values the political prescription
of islam is by its own definition
completely incompatible with western
culture because it seeks to eradicate
western culture that's its purpose
and
i would think this would be some common
ground where progressives left us and
the right should should be able to come
together because the left would
completely get on board with eradicating
these worldviews if attributed to
christians if christians were okay with
beating their wives if christians were
okay with with jailing people who spoke
out against christ of course they have a
problem with it so i think that we
should have the exact same problem with
political islam you know i i remember
when um
when i lived in canada 9 11 happened and
i remember being in comedy clubs and
people saying well you know what this it
doesn't happen in canada it doesn't
happen in europe it doesn't happen in
denmark it's because america has poked
the bear well now it's happening
everywhere
and that's because appeasement is
completely futile
trying to appease
a a group of people
whose world view requires the
eradication of those who appease them
is is is so silly i can't even wrap my
mind around it and today the outrage now
is donald trump called them losers at
life we're seeing this hey donald trump
can you believe donald trump called them
losers at life uh well yeah yeah i can
and you know what he's not the most
elegant eloquent guy neither am i
apparently i've talked about that but
you know why he's saying losers at life
you know why that's different from
people saying this heinous attack and
these monsters because he's trying to
shame them because terrorists because
islamic extremists
can only be punished through shame shame
is worse than death that's why people
have talked about bacon-tipped bullets
or baking creams because of a very
physical world view of heaven when they
reach heaven's gates and and it would be
shameful to be associated with the lowly
pig that's why everyone was so outraged
at abu ghraib when god forbid american
female soldiers stripped terrorists
naked and had dogs barking at them while
they laughed which by the way if i'm an
american and i'm captured by isis and
what they do is have a woman laugh at me
naked with a dog barking
i'll do a jig and thank thank the lord
above that i'm not being burned alive in
a cage so could he find a better way to
express himself the president sure i
would like to see him do so hopefully in
the in the hours that follow but
starting by shaming them and belittling
them
that's that's one hell of a start and
that's why you're seeing a contrast
between him and other leaders and i'm
not the biggest fan of him on every
issue but you know what today i
certainly stand with the president of
the united states and the sentiment of
shaming
these absolute losers at life
in contrast with other world leaders and
as opposed to mincing words
on social media and uh
i i just
everyone's gonna talk about unity today
that's the big thing right everyone's
going to get now you don't need to be
inflammatory right now you shouldn't be
bombastic like you are uh wait it's time
to unify
no it's not time for unity it's time for
an alliance okay and there's a
difference it's time for an alliance of
people who who who value
everything that has created the west who
hold western values here the the values
that allow me to use my iphone and this
internet to upload this video to a
platform freely which hopefully won't
censor it as hate speech who knows now
with the the horrible leviathan that
twitter and google and facebook have
become and choosing to eradicate certain
world views but all it's western values
it allows this even to happen so i'm not
about unity right now how about an
alliance
how about an alliance with other people
who who who
recognize and ally themselves against
the evil
that is political islam because you know
what to unite
with anywhere in the islamic world who
are even enablers of political islam to
unite with enablers of political islam
by proxies to unite with evil and to be
evil
so at this point when everyone's talking
about words and outrage and let's be
sensitive no no let's not be sensitive
in in trying to not hurt people's
feelings but let's be ultra sensitive
let's be ultra sensitive to the truth
let's take our sensitivity in a
different direction let's try and be as
sensitive and as open-minded as humanly
possible to the truth and the truth
right now and the truth that is becoming
clearer and clearer by the day is that
practiced political islam let me make
that clear the prescribed practicing of
political islam as outlined by muhammad
is completely incompatible with western
civilization and it's time for us to
ally against it because it's the great
evil of our time you think i'm right you
think i'm wrong let me know below i'm
sure plenty of you will be mad
i'm easy to find